hey what's up my name is samuel alito
i'm a property investor i've been
investing in property now for in the
last 11 years I've built quite a large
property portfolio I have a lot of very
very successful mentors and mentees and
on this video I wanted to give you my
property investment predictions my
predictions of what's gonna happen to
the economy generally over the next few
years and listen disclaimer this is just
my opinion but I'm pretty sure I'm gonna
be right so you can check this video
back in 2023 and we can have a
conversation so these are the
predictions number one I don't believe
that you're going to be able to be
comfortable much longer and what I mean
by that is the rich are gonna get richer
and the poor are gonna get poorer the
way that health we think is set up even
during this lockdown things that have
happened is unemployment is rising
people are being forced to be
entrepreneurs or to rely on the governor
or government and to rely on jobs so I'm
beginning to see a divide happening oh
not just in the UK all across the world
so that's the first prediction I don't
like this I am a capitalist but I'm a
social capitalist and I like equal
opportunity and that's what I'm trying
to create why do my youtube channel
equal opportunity for everybody so
everyone has the opportunity to have the
information to become wealthy and to
become financially independent but I'll
tell you something people the
middle-class people that just come to
the ball they're on thirty forty
thousand pounds a year and it's okay
they've got two cars take one holiday
year and the relying on the government
and they're relying on the job and
they're relying on an employer those
people potentially it's going to be real
tough it is I don't like that but it's
just what how it's going to be in my
opinion and you're going to see that
over the next that's going to be over
the next two to ten years we're gonna
see that ten years very very very much
so next property prices will dip
following the coronavirus but in many
parts of the north of England prices
will rise that's my prediction
coronavirus right now hasn't really
affected house prices hardly at all but
it'll well in property there's always a
delay even in the 2000 they crash it
took about six months before people
realized there was a crash because home
sellers are stubborn home sellers are
like but my house was valued by the
estate agent for two hundred and fifty
thousand pounds last month and it's like
yeah that was last month but this is
today
and they're not happened in the last
month and they don't get it
there was over half a million properties
that their sales were paused because of
coronavirus the coronavirus made a lot
of impact on the economy so that's my
next prediction property prices are
gonna are going to dip in about six
months but in some areas they're gonna
rise and what do I say that because
people say what a house price is going
to do but house prices it depends on the
area see in places like Liverpool house
prices are bombed out they're only going
to go up you watch four years time from
today
Liverpool house prices would have gone
up a lot but then there's other areas
where they'd have gone down so you can't
just say what a house price is going to
do because every city has its own
economy next is the government are going
to start encouraging spending like crazy
the government are going to be saying
spend spend spend they're going to be
encouraging spending over the next three
six months because they want the economy
to pick back up and when people are not
making money and when people are not
spending money what happens is the
government get less money as well
because of taxes see if I make some
money right now I charge you for my
product and I make some money and then I
use that money to spend money oh they
get the government a winning tax tax tax
they're getting taxed but we're not not
making money and I'm not spending money
the government aren't making money and
if the government are making money the
government are not happy the government
about to pay a lot of money out I know
they've printed money that's a whole
other story but I've had to pay a lot of
money out with furloughs and different
things so they're gonna be encouraging
like crazy you dispense banks parents my
advice over the next three six months
don't spend spend spend save and invest
invest in properties smartly and
strategically and make sure that you
invest in yourself but don't spend spend
spend on stupid stuff right now that's
what they'll be encouraging that's what
no what they'll say yeah sure you can
have a personal loan to go on holiday
don't do it next more millionaires will
be made than ever before right now
there's about 20 million millionaires in
the planet that's going to go up I
believe that as a result of the the
lockdown that's happened as a result
Corona that's happened people that were
entrepreneurial employees are probably
going to be saying you know what I'm
gonna really push this hard
I believe the property investors are
gonna be like oh my goodness I need to I
need to start thinking about how to
scale this and honestly what's going to
happen is good
more millionaires a lot more
millionaires you'll see them on my
youtube channel I just had an interview
dr. John Demartini he said he's made
more money during lockdown than ever
before more millionaires more poor
people divides getting bigger that's my
that was my first point next interest
rates will remain low for years I
believe interest rates are going to
remain very low people are saying they
might shoot up to 15% again like they
were back in the day don't think that's
gonna happen
interest rates are gonna stay low you
can fix interest rates right now to up
to you 10 years I don't think they're
going to shoot up anytime soon next more
legislations going to come into the
service accommodation market and it will
increase the demand what do I mean by
that so there's some certain investment
strategies and investment types where
they're very legislated service
accommodation is not one that is right
now you can rent out a property on air
B&B and as long as it doesn't it doesn't
break the head least or the mortgage
terms there's no licensing there's no
legislation around serviced
accommodation I think that that's going
to slowly start to change and as that
starts to change it's going to put
people off because at the moment service
accommodation is such a right fantastic
thing to do more people who do service
combination now than ever because of
section 24 because buy-to-let landlords
got penalized so they're having to be
creative and rent their property out on
booking.com and on Airbnb to avoid the
tax changes of section 24
they're also realizing that it gives way
more cash flow anyway so more people are
doing it and it's great but it's going
to get legislated it's going to put some
people off and the people that get
around the loopholes get around the
problems are gonna get richer and richer
again so that's my opinion of serviced
accommodation once you get legislated
and watch me step around it and continue
to make money while others get put off
next HMOs will become more and more
popular and rents will rise rapidly HMOs
are gonna get very very very popular why
because as unemployment rises and as
divorce rates go up what's gonna happen
is one household will turn into two
household and people that are paying for
a studio fight or a two-bit apartment
they're gonna suddenly want more
affordable accommodation and and they're
going to look to when rooms so rooms
right now or a bit like what you live in
a room that's kind of weird you share a
kitchen that's not going to be weird in
the next few years
more popular and rents are gonna go up
so hate Simoes are gonna become very
very popular
of course there's there's the issues of
licensing legislation I don't think HMOs
are gonna get more regulated there's the
issue of article 4 article 4 is given
coming to more areas which is going to
mean that you're gonna need planning
permission so the way to get around that
is to buy HMOs now so that you have the
grandfather rights
next I will have more success tips than
ever before and my training company will
expand internationally during these
years of opportunity I believe that
because the rich are going to get richer
because things are going to be changing
I don't think there's many people like
me who were super successful in property
and multi millionaires that are putting
their stuff out on YouTube every single
day and as I do that people are going to
watch the YouTube videos like you
watching right now you're gonna be like
that's interesting and you're gonna want
to invest in yourself I have a training
company by the way don't let it twist it
I have a training company because I want
to help people and because I've vowed
that if I ever became successful I
wasn't going to one of those rich people
to hide away I don't even take a salary
from the training company so I have a
training company and it's going to blow
up it's already big I already have the
biggest wealth creation training company
in the UK probably definitely biggest
property training company and I think
it's gonna go international because I
think more people from overseas like
Holland and America and Germany and
Africa and China are gonna be wanting to
also learn about property and I taste
something here in the UK and over in
America and in Holland is kind of the
same thing and I'm now putting my
courses online so I think it's gonna
borrow and I'm excited about that
I'm excited about the legacy it's going
to lead I'm excited about being able to
help some of the people become rich that
would have become poor because the rich
and the poor divide is getting bigger
and bigger the government yeah he's
crazy I don't want to bash the
government I don't want to bash the
media the media are just gonna keep
saying stories to try and get views but
that's always happen and always will
happen so anyway that's my prediction is
2020 right now is June 2020 so I hope
you're watching this
in June 2013 10 years after this came
out you're gonna go holy moly house
Samuel Wright on
every single point and I'm gonna say not
because i'm a profiteer not because i
have a quick crystal ball but because
I've observed history I've got good
mentors I can see patterns I know where
people are pushing things and their
agendas and it's just obvious what's
going to happen I predicted so much in
the past and have been right I believe
you section 24 impact I believe you the
article for impact I predicted what
happened in 2009 when I was investing
they've only mean not to invest I've
always been right up until now so I'm
happy to be wrong I don't think it's
gonna happen
what do you think comment your thoughts
below subscribe to the channel so in
2013 you'll be able to look back and be
like damn he was right
[Music]